Most of us have heard the term psychopath and may have an image of what a psychopath looks like, whether that's Charles Manson or Ted Bundy or even the fictional Hannibal Lecter. The word itself, psychopath, brings to mind horror movies, serial killers, arson, and other mayhem. But psychopathy isn't just about terrible people who commit heinous crimes. Psychopathy is more common than most people realize. People with psychopathic traits show less empathy and empathy, remorse than other people. They may lie, cheat, and steal, but they may also be friendly, smart, and basically unremarkable. In other words, impossible to pick out of a crowd. Although severe
我们大多数人都听说过“精神病态”这个词，并且可能对精神病态者有一个形象的认知，无论是查尔斯·曼森、泰德·邦迪，还是虚构的汉尼拔·莱克特。精神病态这个词本身就会让人联想到恐怖电影、连环杀手、纵火犯和其他混乱行为。但精神病态不仅仅是指那些犯下滔天罪行的可怕之人。精神病态比大多数人意识到的更为普遍。具有精神病态特质的人表现出的同理心和悔恨感比其他人更少。他们可能会撒谎、欺骗和偷窃，但也可能表现得友好、聪明，基本上平平无奇。换句话说，在人群中根本无法辨认出来。虽然严重的
psychopathy affects just about 1% of people, some research suggests that close to 30% of us have some level of psychopathic traits. And we may even know people who fall under this broad umbrella. So what do researchers know about the causes of psychopathy? How is psychopathy related to other mental health disorders? Are psychopaths born? Or are they made by their family life, by their environment? Are there effective treatments for it? Can children show psychopathic traits?
精神病态仅影响约1%的人口，但一些研究表明，我们中近30%的人具有一定程度的精神病态特质。我们甚至可能认识处于这个广泛范畴内的人。那么，研究人员对精神病态的成因了解多少呢？精神病态与其他心理健康障碍有何关联？精神病态者是天生的吗？还是由他们的家庭生活或环境造成的？有有效的治疗方法吗？儿童会表现出精神病态特质吗？
And if so, how early? And if you recognize psychopathic traits and someone close to you, what should you do? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Abigail Marsh, a professor of psychology and neuroscience at Georgetown University. She studies psychopathy as well as its opposite, extreme altruism and pro-social emotions,
如果是这样，多早会出现？如果你在身边的人身上发现了精神病态特质，你应该怎么做？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是乔治城大学心理学和神经科学教授阿比盖尔·马什博士。她研究精神病态以及与其相反的极端利他主义和亲社会情绪，
such as empathy, compassion, and remorse. She's studied both psychopaths and extreme altruists, such as people who donate kidneys to strangers. And she's interested in exploring the emotional processes and the brain differences that can explain both of these extremes of human behavior. In addition to her many scientific publications, Dr. Marsh is author of the award-winning book The Fear Factor, How One Emotion Connects Altruists, Psychopaths, and Everyone in Between. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Marsh.
例如同理心、同情心和悔恨感。她研究过精神病态者和极端利他主义者，比如那些向陌生人捐献肾脏的人。她有兴趣探索能够解释这两种极端人类行为的情绪过程和大脑差异。除了许多科学出版物外，马什博士还是获奖书籍《恐惧因素：一种情绪如何连接利他主义者、精神病态者以及介于两者之间的所有人》的作者。感谢您加入我们，马什博士。
Thank you so much for having me. I'm thrilled to be here. So let's start as we often do on this podcast with a definition. There are a lot of misconceptions about psychopathy and psychopaths. I mentioned some of them in my introduction, like the fact that people may think that all psychopaths are violent criminals. What are the traits that define psychopathy and how do they manifest themselves in people's behavior? The most important thing to remember about psychopathy is that it's a personality construct. It's based on a constellation of three kinds of personality traits, which include at the real core of the construct is callousness, meaning insensitivity to other people's suffering. truly not caring about other people's welfare. In addition to that, people who are psychopathic
非常感谢邀请我。我很高兴能来到这里。那么，我们像往常一样从定义开始。关于精神病态和精神病态者存在很多误解。我在介绍中提到了一些，比如人们可能认为所有的精神病态者都是暴力罪犯。定义精神病态的特质是什么？它们在人们的行为中是如何表现出来的？关于精神病态，最重要的一点是它是一个人格结构。它基于三种人格特质的组合，其中该结构真正的核心是冷酷无情，即对他人的痛苦不敏感，真正不关心他人的福祉。除此之外，具有精神病态的人
tend to have bold, sort of dominant, fearless personality styles. And they also tend to be relatively disinhibited. So they have trouble controlling their behavior, trouble managing impulses. And if you have all three of those personality traits, we would say that you're psychopathic, especially if you have them to a really large degree. But they can manifest in all sorts of different ways behaviorally. Sometimes, more often in men than women, although not exclusively, they do manifest as aggression and criminal violence. And people who are psychopathic who do show those behaviors, obviously, we care about understanding them.
往往具有大胆、某种程度上占主导地位、无所畏惧的人格风格。他们也往往相对缺乏抑制力。所以他们难以控制自己的行为，难以管理冲动。如果你具备所有这三种人格特质，我们就会说你是精神病态的，特别是如果你具备这些特质的程度非常高。但它们在行为上可以以各种不同的方式表现出来。有时，男性比女性更常见，尽管并非绝对，它们表现为攻击性和犯罪暴力。而那些确实表现出这些行为的精神病态者，显然，我们关心的是去理解他们。
We want to try to prevent those outcomes if we can. But most people who are psychopathic are not violent criminals. That's actually the exception. It's much more likely to manifest in all sorts of smaller antisocial behaviors in daily life from being lying and manipulator to sort of being a bully and threatening people to get what you want, to maybe committing lower level crimes related to theft or con artistry, that sort of thing. So psychopathy is not an official diagnosis in the diagnostic and statistical manual of
如果可以的话，我们想尝试预防这些结果。但大多数精神病态者并不是暴力罪犯。那实际上是例外。它更有可能在日常生活中表现为各种较小的反社会行为，从撒谎和操纵，到某种程度上的欺凌和威胁他人以达到目的，再到可能犯下与盗窃或诈骗有关的低级别犯罪，诸如此类。所以精神病态并不是《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》中的一个正式诊断，对吧？
mental disorders, right? Exactly. This is one of the many confusing things about it. Yeah. Why is that? It's a great question. And it's one that you'll, there are slightly different explanations depending on who you ask, because of course the diagnostic and statistical manual is the result of a lot of people working together
没错。这是关于它的许多令人困惑的事情之一。是的。为什么会这样？这是一个很好的问题。而且根据你问的对象，会有略微不同的解释，因为当然，《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》是许多人共同工作
and making decisions together. The basic idea is that, so psychopathy is an old construct. It was first formalized, depending on who you ask in the maybe late 1800s or certainly no later than the early 1900s, maybe most famously by Herbie Cleckley, the great psychiatrist in his book, The Mask of Sanity, which is a fantastic book, if you're interested in psychopathy. I highly recommend it. And he was the first to come up with a list of traits that typify people with psychopathy. And a version of those traits made it into early versions of the DSM often under other names,
并共同做出决定的结果。基本观点是，精神病态是一个古老的结构。它首次被正式化，取决于你问谁，可能是在19世纪末，或者肯定不晚于20世纪初，也许最著名的是由伟大的精神病学家赫比·克莱克利在他的书《理智的面具》中提出的，如果你对精神病态感兴趣，这是一本很棒的书。我强烈推荐它。他是第一个列出典型精神病态者特质清单的人。这些特质的一个版本进入了DSM的早期版本，通常以其他名称出现，
you know, something other than psychopathy. The most reason version of the DSM has a disorder in it called antisocial personality disorder, which is sometimes confused with psychopathy. And it's not, it overlaps with psychopathy, but it's not the same. It mostly indexes persistent criminal behavior, again, and it focuses much less on the personality features of the patient than the psychopathy does, where a psychopathy is really strictly about personality, antisocial personality disorder is mostly about behavior.
你知道，除了精神病态之外的其他名称。DSM的最新版本中有一个名为反社会人格障碍的障碍，有时会与精神病态混淆。它不是，它与精神病态有重叠，但并不相同。它主要指向持续的犯罪行为，同样，它比精神病态更少关注患者的人格特征，精神病态确实严格关于人格，而反社会人格障碍主要关于行为。
And so you can have lots of people who have antisocial personality disorder would not qualify as being psychopathic, or at least not highly so, and vice versa is also true. Actually, the closest thing to psychopathy in the current DSM is a diagnosis in children, which is conduct disorder with limited prosocial emotions. Now, if a child qualifies for that diagnosis, we still wouldn't call them a psychopath.
所以你可以有很多患有反社会人格障碍的人，他们不会被归类为精神病态，或者至少不是高度精神病态，反之亦然。实际上，当前DSM中最接近精神病态的是儿童的一种诊断，即伴有有限亲社会情绪的品行障碍。现在，如果一个孩子符合该诊断，我们仍然不会称他们为精神病态者。
And in fact, I try to avoid now using the term psychopath and sticking with person-first language, as we do for lots of disorders. But that's not a universal practice in the field, certainly. And in any case, we would never call a child a psychopath ever. And we usually try to even avoid calling them a psychopathic. We say maybe they're at risk for psychopathy or they have psychopathic traits. And a child who has a conduct disorder with limited prosocial emotions shows persistent antisocial behavior, including aggression, bullying, making threats, lying, manipulating, delinquency,
事实上，我现在尽量避免使用“精神病态者”这个词，而是坚持使用“以人为本”的语言，就像我们对待许多疾病一样。但这在领域内肯定不是一种普遍的做法。无论如何，我们绝不会称一个孩子为精神病态者。我们通常甚至尽量避免称他们为“精神病态的”。我们可能会说他们有精神病态的风险，或者他们有精神病态特质。而一个患有伴有有限亲社会情绪的品行障碍的儿童会表现出持续的反社会行为，包括攻击、欺凌、威胁、撒谎、操纵、违纪，
all the things that you tend to see in children who have psychopathy. And in addition, limited pro-social emotions refers to having an uncaring personality with limited empathy or remorse. and tending not to show strong emotions, in particular emotions like fear and sadness and love. And so if you have a child who qualifies for that diagnosis, they're at very high risk for developing psychopathy. And you've done quite a bit of work with children who manifest these traits. And I know that it's highly, highly difficult for parents who have such children.
所有你在患有精神病态的儿童身上往往会看到的行为。此外，有限的亲社会情绪是指拥有冷漠的人格，同理心或悔恨感有限。并且倾向于不表现出强烈的情绪，特别是像恐惧、悲伤和爱这样的情绪。所以如果你有一个符合该诊断的孩子，他们发展成精神病态的风险非常高。你对表现出这些特质的儿童做了相当多的工作。我知道对于有这类孩子的父母来说，这非常非常困难。
How do you help them deal with this? Are there treatments for the children that maybe can nip this behavior in the butt? And then how do you work with the parents? It's a really difficult problem when parents have children who have these traits. Unfortunately, as many people know, there's a real lack of trained child psychologist and psychiatrists to start with. So parents of children with any severe psychological disorder already struggled to find somebody who can provide good treatment. There's a particular lack of people who are trained and experienced in treating children who have serious externalizing behavior disorders. So that's conduct disorder, oppositional defiant disorder, et cetera.
你如何帮助他们处理这个问题？是否有针对儿童的治疗方法可以把这种行为扼杀在摇篮里？然后你如何与父母合作？当父母有这些特质的孩子时，这是一个非常困难的问题。不幸的是，正如许多人所知，首先，真正缺乏训练有素的儿童心理学家和精神科医生。因此，患有任何严重心理障碍的儿童的父母已经在努力寻找能够提供良好治疗的人。特别缺乏受过训练且有经验治疗患有严重外化行为障碍的儿童的人。也就是品行障碍、对立违抗性障碍等。
I tend to suspect that those are not the kinds of disorders. Most people go into child psychology or psychiatry to treat. You know, and it is, it can be really hard to feel compassion for people who treat others badly. I mean, this is a natural human tendency. But I think it's so important to remember that, you know, children don't choose to have the psychological symptoms and traits that they do. And just as we wouldn't blame a child with autism or a child with anxiety for the symptoms that we show, I think it's wildly inappropriate to blame a child with conduct disorder or oppositional defined disorder for their symptoms. Just because those symptoms do hurt other people, which doesn't quite fit most people's mental profile of what a psychological disorder is. We think of people who are not until the ill as having maybe disordered thoughts or having lots of anxiety and suffering and distress.
我倾向于怀疑这些不是大多数人进入儿童心理学或精神病学领域想要治疗的那类障碍。你知道，对那些对待他人很糟糕的人产生同情心确实很难。我的意思是，这是一种自然的人类倾向。但我认为记住这一点非常重要，你知道，孩子们并没有选择他们所表现出的心理症状和特质。就像我们不会因为自闭症儿童或焦虑症儿童表现出的症状而责怪他们一样，我认为因为品行障碍或对立违抗性障碍的症状而责怪孩子是非常不恰当的。仅仅因为这些症状确实伤害了他人，这并不太符合大多数人对心理障碍的心理画像。我们认为心理不健康的人可能有紊乱的思想，或者有大量的焦虑、痛苦和困扰。
That's kind of the prototype. And conduct disorder and psychopathy just don't fit that mold. The children with these conditions often deny there's anything wrong with them because being fairly narcissistic is a big part of the personality profile of psychopathy. And that is also one of the reasons it's very hard to treat. Of course, if you don't think there's anything wrong with you, the problem is with everybody else. You're not going to be super receptive to people trying to change things about you. Unfortunately, psychopathy developed a reputation for being untreatable based on some papers that came out in the late 1900s. But that's not true.
这就是原型。而品行障碍和精神病态根本不符合那种模式。患有这些疾病的儿童通常否认他们有任何问题，因为相当自恋是精神病态人格画像的重要组成部分。这也是它非常难以治疗的原因之一。当然，如果你认为自己没有任何问题，问题就在于其他人。你不会非常乐意接受人们试图改变你身上的事情。不幸的是，精神病态基于20世纪末发表的一些论文，获得了无法治疗的名声。但那不是真的。
It's a personality disorder. And personality disorders are notoriously difficult to treat, but certainly not impossible. And especially if we can identify children who are at risk for developing psychopathy, it is treatable. But it does require time and a lot of effort. And in some cases, a lot of resources, which is unfortunate. The most effective treatments tend to be some combination of training aimed at how parents respond to their children. And I say this with caution because it's too easy for people to assume that if you are addressing parents' behavior to help treat the condition, that it's the parents' behavior that cause the condition. And I think that's a huge method I'd like to dispel.
这是一种人格障碍。人格障碍以难以治疗而闻名，但绝非不可能。特别是如果我们能识别出有发展成精神病态风险的儿童，它是可以治疗的。但这确实需要时间和大量的努力。在某些情况下，需要大量的资源，这很不幸。最有效的治疗方法往往是针对父母如何回应孩子的一些训练组合。我谨慎地说这一点，因为人们太容易假设如果你通过解决父母的行为来帮助治疗这种疾病，那么就是父母的行为导致了这种疾病。我认为这是一个我想消除的巨大误区。
We know that behavioral therapy, a lot of it administered by parents, is a really effective treatment for children with autism. You have to use very specific kinds of interpersonal behaviors to help them develop. But we don't think that parents cause autism, or at least not anymore, right? We used to think that. This used to be just accepted wisdom in psychology, that refrigerator mothers cause their children's autism. Unfortunately, we're still in that place with psychopathy where a lot of people assume it's
我们知道行为疗法，其中很多是由父母实施的，是治疗自闭症儿童的一种非常有效的疗法。你必须使用非常特定的人际行为来帮助他们发展。但我们并不认为父母导致了自闭症，或者至少不再这样认为，对吧？我们过去确实这样认为。这在心理学中曾经是公认的智慧，即“冰箱母亲”导致了她们孩子的自闭症。不幸的是，我们在精神病态方面仍然处于那个阶段，很多人假设是
parents' behavior that causes it. So even though that's not true, there aren't. things that parents can do to help, but they're not the sort of behaviors that parents would naturally come up with on their own. Usually, there's a number of different kinds of formalized therapeutic approaches that work. Most of them emphasize how to provide children with extremely clear, consistent, positive reinforcement for doing the right thing and ensuring that they're not reinforced for doing the wrong things, right? Don't get into the tantrums. Don't get into the manipulation because if you give into those behaviors, you reinforce them and you make sure that
父母的行为导致了它。所以即使那不是真的，也没有。父母可以做些事情来提供帮助，但它们不是父母会自然而然想到的那种行为。通常，有许多不同种类的正式治疗方法是有效的。大多数方法强调如何为孩子提供极其清晰、一致、积极的强化，以鼓励他们做正确的事情，并确保他们不会因为做错误的事情而得到强化，对吧？不要陷入发脾气。不要陷入操纵，因为如果你屈服于这些行为，你就会强化它们，并确保
they come back. They also reinforce not relying on punishments to change children's behavior. One of the really difficult things about psychopathy is the fearless temperament that it seems to be rooted in. And that's how punishment works is through the fear system. And I don't mean, you know, violent punishment necessarily. But anytime you avoid a behavior that you think will be punished, that's fear talking. You're like, I don't want that bad thing to happen, so I won't do this thing I'm not supposed to do. And children who were psychopathic, many of the ones I've worked with truly are fearless. They say they have never felt afraid of anything. They don't report feeling any, you know, high autonomic arousal sensations in their body under threat. And they have difficulty
它们再次出现。他们还强调不依赖惩罚来改变孩子的行为。精神病态最困难的事情之一是它似乎根植于无所畏惧的气质。惩罚是通过恐惧系统起作用的。我指的不是，你知道，必然是暴力惩罚。但任何时候你避免一种你认为会受到惩罚的行为，那就是恐惧在说话。你会想，我不希望那件坏事发生，所以我不会做我不应该做的事情。而精神病态的儿童，我合作过的许多孩子确实是无所畏惧的。他们说他们从未对任何事情感到害怕。他们在威胁下不会报告感到任何，你知道，身体上的高自主唤醒感觉。而且他们有困难
describing what fear feels like. And so you can't punish a child into behaving who doesn't feel fear and P.S., that's not a good parenting strategy for any child. And the other thing is that children who are psychopathic often seem very resistant to affection or they don't seem to get a lot out of affection for reasons we don't really understand yet. And so sometimes parents will sometimes not be as outwardly affectionate towards these children, both because they're frustrated by them and both because the child doesn't seem to want it. But there's some of it that it's to suggest that they should do exactly the opposite, which is counterintuitive and that they should be provide extra big sort of social positive cues, more affection, more smiles, more positive
描述恐惧是什么感觉。所以你不能通过惩罚来让一个不感到恐惧的孩子表现良好，顺便说一句，这对任何孩子来说都不是一个好的育儿策略。另一件事是，精神病态的儿童通常看起来对情感非常抵触，或者由于我们尚未真正理解的原因，他们似乎从情感中得不到太多东西。所以有时父母有时不会对这些孩子表现出那么多的外在情感，既因为他们对孩子感到沮丧，也因为孩子似乎并不想要它。但有一些证据表明，他们应该做完全相反的事情，这违反直觉，即他们应该提供额外的大量的某种社会积极线索，更多的情感，更多的微笑，更多的积极
physical touches than seem natural and that the child even seems to want. And we know there's some evidence that parents who use these types of approaches with even very high-risk children can see good effects in the long run. But it's challenging. I won't lie. So is it possible then to teach a child that may be even harder with adults? but to teach a child who has these traits, to feel fear, to understand fear, and to feel remorse, which they apparently don't. These are really big open questions. One of the real problems with the field of psychopathy is that not enough mental health resources
身体接触，比看起来自然的，甚至比孩子看起来想要的更多。我们知道有一些证据表明，对即使是高风险儿童使用这些方法的父母，从长远来看也能看到良好的效果。但这很有挑战性。我不会撒谎。那么，是否有可能教一个孩子，这在成人身上可能更难？但教一个有这些特质的孩子去感受恐惧，去理解恐惧，去感受悔恨，而他们显然没有这些感觉？这些是非常大的开放性问题。精神病态领域真正的问题之一是，多年来没有足够的心理健康资源
have been devoted to trying to understand or treat it over the years. It's very common. Conduct disorder affects, depending on the estimate, up to 7% of children at some point during development, social defiant disorder even more. And there are as many as two to three percent of children have high levels of limited social emotions during development. These are not rare conditions. Psychopathy is at least as common as bipolar disorder or anorexia or some other disorders
被投入到试图理解或治疗它上。它非常普遍。品行障碍影响了，根据估计，高达7%的儿童在发育过程中的某个阶段，对立违抗性障碍甚至更多。并且有多达2%到3%的儿童在发育过程中具有高水平的有限亲社会情绪。这些不是罕见的疾病。精神病态至少和双相情感障碍或厌食症或其他一些疾病一样普遍
that we think of as not that rare. And yet very, very few resources have been devoted to trying to understand how to treat it. And so there's a lot of things we don't know. There's not one single pharmaceutical that's every single pharmaceutical that's ever been developed specifically to treat externalizing behavior disorders, for example. And so children with these disorders get treated with a lot of other kinds of medications that were developed to treat other things. Some of them do seem to help.
我们认为这些疾病并不罕见。然而，很少有资源被投入到试图理解如何治疗它上。所以有很多事情我们不知道。没有一种单一的药物，曾经开发出的每一种药物都是专门用于治疗外化行为障碍的，例如。所以患有这些疾病的儿童会接受许多其他种类的药物治疗，这些药物是为治疗其他疾病而开发的。其中一些似乎确实有帮助。
So, for example, stimulant medications used to treat ADHD do help some children who are at risk for psychopathy. It shouldn't be the first line treatment. You should always start with the parent management training type of approaches, but it sometimes is a nice adjuvant. It will sort of increase the effectiveness of the behavioral treatment. Sometimes mood stabilizers are used and they can be effective. And even antipsychotic medications are sometimes used and can be effective. Although I think it's risky to use these drugs for a long time in children. Do they actually increase the capacity of children to feel emotions like fear
所以，例如，用于治疗ADHD的兴奋剂药物确实对一些有精神病态风险的儿童有帮助。它不应该是第一线治疗。你应该总是从父母管理训练类型的方法开始，但它有时是一个很好的辅助手段。它会某种程度上增加行为治疗的有效性。有时会使用情绪稳定剂，它们可能是有效的。甚至抗精神病药物有时也会被使用并且可能是有效的。尽管我认为长期在儿童身上使用这些药物是有风险的。它们是否真的增加了儿童感受恐惧等情绪的能力
that although we think of them as quote negative emotions are incredibly important for adaptive social development and social functioning? Probably not. And to be honest, it's not surprising that pharmaceutical companies don't seem that keen on developing medications that will make children more fearful. It's not really. Nobody feels comfortable with that, right? Which I get. And again, it's too bad. It's easy for people to forget what a useful emotion fear is in the right, you know, to a degree, Right. Obviously excessive fear is no good. But some low level of fear is incredibly important because, and this is what a lot of my research centers around, not only does it help you respond to negative feedback from other people people, but the capacity to feel fear helps you empathize with other people's fear. And that's one of these critical social mechanisms that prevents people from doing things that cause other people fear. And this is a problem in psychopathy because they don't often feel fear very strongly themselves. They don't understand it in other people, and they literally don't understand why it's wrong to cause it in other people. It's a huge problem. Now, that said, it may be possible to increase other positive
尽管我们认为它们是所谓的“负面情绪”，但它们对于适应性社会发展和社会功能极其重要？可能不会。老实说，制药公司似乎不太热衷于开发让儿童变得更恐惧的药物，这并不令人惊讶。这真的不是。没有人对此感到舒服，对吧？我明白。再说一次，这太糟糕了。人们很容易忘记恐惧在适当的程度下是一种多么有用的情绪，对吧？显然过度的恐惧是不好的。但某种低水平的恐惧极其重要，因为，这就是我很多研究的中心，它不仅能帮助你对来自他人的负面反馈做出反应，而且感受恐惧的能力能帮助你对他人的恐惧产生同理心。这是防止人们做出导致他人恐惧的行为的关键社会机制之一。这是一个精神病态的问题，因为他们自己往往不会强烈地感到恐惧。他们不理解他人的恐惧，而且他们确实不理解为什么在他人身上引起恐惧是错误的。这是一个巨大的问题。话虽如此，通过我一直在谈论的这些行为性的某种父母管理技术，增加儿童的精神病态中的其他积极
social emotions in children with psychopathy through these behavioral sort of parent management techniques I've been talking about, mostly by causing them to view other people as socially rewarding because that's a really good thing. If you view interactions with people, and having positive interactions with people is intrinsically rewarding, oftentimes that's enough to keep your behavior, your social behavior, um, on the right side of things all by itself. The problem is that kids at risk for psychopathy engage in a lot of behaviors that
社会情绪可能是可能的，主要是通过让他们将他人视为社会性奖励，因为那是一件非常好的事情。如果你认为与人的互动，以及与人进行积极的互动在本质上是有益的，通常这本身就足以让你的行为，你的社会行为，保持在正确的一面。问题在于，有精神病态风险的孩子参与了很多行为，这些行为
bother other people that, you know, from being annoying to being actually harmful. Uh, and then you get negative feedback from people and you can end up in these negative reinforcement spirals where you just view other people as really, um, not really worth, uh, caring about. or treating well at all. And that's what you want to avoid. And if you, you know, the right approach is taken, you can end up with a child who's maybe temperamentally pretty fearless and not
困扰他人，你知道，从令人讨厌到实际上是有害的。然后你从人们那里得到负面反馈，你最终可能会陷入这些负面强化螺旋，你只是将他人视为真的，嗯，不值得关心。或者根本不值得善待。而这就是你想要避免的。如果你，你知道，采取了正确的方法，你最终可能会得到一个孩子，他可能在气质上相当无畏，并不是
the most caring person in the world, but can be totally functional and lead a perfectly good life and have good friendships and relationships. Let's talk for a minute about causes, because I know you've done some research, including brain imaging that found some interesting differences in the brains of children who are manifesting this disorder. And then the other question, is, are these things genetic? Do we know? Understanding the causes of psychopathy is obviously really important to coming up with more effective treatments. And again, what the psychopathy research community desperately needs is more resources from mental health organizations. You know, funding organizations to
世界上最关心他人的人，但可以完全正常运作，过上非常好的生活，并拥有良好的友谊和关系。让我们花一分钟谈谈成因，因为我知道你做了一些研究，包括脑成像，发现患有这种疾病的儿童的大脑有一些有趣的差异。然后另一个问题是，这些东西是遗传的吗？我们知道吗？理解精神病态的成因显然对于提出更有效的治疗方法非常重要。同样，精神病态研究界迫切需要心理健康组织提供更多资源。你知道，资助组织去
take psychopathy seriously as a mental illness that needs, you know, resources poured into trying to understand it better. That said, we've made some progress. For a while now, brain imaging research in children who have psychopathic traits has been pointing to a relatively consistent finding, which is that if you look at large groups of kids who have serious conduct problems, so aggression, externalizing, delinquency, that sort of thing. Only the children who have psychopathic personality traits, so the low empathy, lower remorse and uncaring traits, show reduced activity in a structure called the Imigilab. And you see the opposite effect in children who have equally serious, aggressive, externalizing behavior, but don't have the
认真对待精神病态，将其视为一种需要投入资源去更好地理解它的精神疾病。话虽如此，我们已经取得了一些进展。一段时间以来，对患有精神病态特质的儿童进行的脑成像研究一直指向一个相对一致的发现，即如果你观察患有严重品行问题的大群体儿童，即攻击性、外化、违纪等。只有那些具有精神病态人格特质，即低同理心、较低悔恨感和冷漠特质的儿童，在一种称为杏仁核的结构中表现出活动减少。而在患有同样严重的攻击性、外化行为但没有
psychopathic traits. They actually show increased activity in amygdala. And this is one of those interesting cases where brain imaging has told us something really important to understanding the phenomenon and to identify appropriate treatments that different kids with conduct disorder, aggression, et cetera, show completely different mechanisms that seem to be underlying their antisocial behaviors. And that's really important to know. And so what we know about the amygdala is it does a lot of things, first of all.
精神病态特质的儿童身上，你会看到相反的效果。他们实际上在杏仁核中表现出活动增加。这是脑成像告诉我们对于理解这种现象和识别适当治疗方法非常重要的有趣案例之一，即患有品行障碍、攻击性等的不同孩子，表现出似乎是其反社会行为基础的完全不同的机制。了解这一点非常重要。所以我们对杏仁核的了解是，首先，它做了很多事情。
It's a densely interconnected structure in the brain. It's there, you have two amygdala, one on each side, and they're sort of deep under the cortex. And they're evolutionarily ancient. One of the important things they do is regulate the body's fear responding. So they coordinate responses to threats. And people who have lost their amygdalas due to either genetic disorders or in some cases, injuries. do seem to have kind of muted fear responding as a result. So we think the amygdala is important for fear.
它是大脑中一个高度互联的结构。它在那里，你有两个杏仁核，每一侧一个，它们某种程度上位于皮层深处。而且它们在进化上是古老的。它们所做的重要事情之一是调节身体的恐惧反应。所以它们协调对威胁的反应。而由于遗传疾病或在某些情况下受伤而失去杏仁核的人，确实因此有某种程度的迟钝的恐惧反应。所以我们认为杏仁核对恐惧很重要。
It also definitely plays an important role in sort of regulating social behavior, although exactly how it's doing that is less clear yet. And we think that because in children who are at risk for psychopathy, the amygdala is not developing correctly. It ends up being too small on average, especially earlier in development. And it's less active in response to the things. that it should respond to. For example, the sight of somebody else who's afraid. That seems to be at the heart of the problems that we see in children with psychopathy. Now, it's not the only problem
它也肯定在某种程度上调节社会行为方面发挥重要作用，尽管它究竟是如何做到这一点的尚不清楚。我们认为这是因为在有精神病态风险的儿童中，杏仁核没有正确发育。它平均来说最终太小了，特别是在发育早期。并且在响应它应该响应的事物时，它的活跃度较低。例如，看到别人感到害怕。这似乎是我们在精神病态儿童身上看到的问题的核心。现在，它不是唯一的
in their brains, but it's the one that has been the most consistently identified and the one that I think is likely to be central to their disorders. Is the disorder heritable? Well, every psychological phenomenon is at least partially heritable. So the same is certainly true for psychopathy as well. A giant meta-analysis that came out in, I think it was nature genetic several years ago, looked at the heritability of lots and lots of different outcomes, including psychological outcomes, and found that on average, psychological traits like personality traits, things like anxiety, psychological disorders, are an average 50% heritable, which means half of the variance can be accounted for by genetic factors. And the same seems to be true for psychopathic.
他们大脑中的问题，但它是最一致被识别出的问题，也是我认为很可能是他们疾病核心的问题。这种疾病是可遗传的吗？嗯，每一种心理现象至少部分是可遗传的。所以精神病态肯定也是如此。几年前发表在《自然遗传学》上的一项巨大的荟萃分析，观察了许多不同结果的遗传力，包括心理结果，发现平均而言，像人格特质、焦虑、心理障碍等心理特质，平均有50%是可遗传的，这意味着一半的差异可以由遗传因素来解释。精神病态似乎也是如此。
So about half of the variance is accounted for by genetic factors. That does mean that if somebody else in a child's family shows signs of psychopathy, that child is at higher risk for developing psychopathic traits. But of course, that is a long way from saying that psychopathy is inborn or innate or hardwired. At every stage of development, genetic potential is interacting with environmental factors to drive outcomes. And so it's pretty clear that features of a child's environment will also change. shape the degree to which any sort of latent potential for psychopathy gets expressed. That raises another question in my mind, which is, I think that some people confuse
所以大约一半的差异是由遗传因素解释的。这确实意味着如果一个孩子家庭中的其他人表现出精神病态的迹象，该孩子发展出精神病态特质的风险就更高。但当然，这离说精神病态是天生的、先天的或硬连线的还很远。在发育的每个阶段，遗传潜力都在与环境因素相互作用以驱动结果。所以很明显，孩子环境的特征也会改变。塑造任何某种精神病态的潜在潜力被表达的程度。这在我的脑海中引发了另一个问题，即我认为有些人混淆了
psychopathy and sociopathy. And I'm just wondering if you could explain how they're different and how they're similar. Absolutely. Psychopathy, I will emphasize, is technically the more scientific term. So, for example, there are no scientific societies for the study of sociopathy. That's not a thing. There is one for the study. science of psychopathy. I'm a member, of course. There are no, as far as I'm aware, there are no sort of scientifically validated measures for assessing sociopathy. There are not journal articles describing sociopathy. It's more of a sort of popular term for describing highly antisocial people. It has been used off and on in the past to describe people with
精神病态和社会病态。我只是想知道你是否能解释它们有何不同以及有何相似之处。绝对可以。我强调，精神病态在技术上是更科学的术语。所以，例如，没有用于研究社会病态的科学协会。那不是一回事。有一个用于研究精神病态科学的协会。我当然是成员。据我所知，没有某种经过科学验证的评估社会病态的测量方法。没有描述社会病态的期刊文章。它更多是一种描述高度反社会人群的流行术语。它在过去曾断断续续地被用来描述患有
the diagnosis of antisocial personality disorder. And so, I would say that sometimes that's what it's used to mean. Other times it's used to mean people whose antisocial behavior is mostly a result of social forces. So people who were not born at particularly high risk of becoming antisocial, but due to really terrible things that happen to them often in childhood, experiencing extreme neglect or trauma or abuse, developed antisocial behavior as a result. Now, that's not even the normative consequence of experiencing abuse. use trauma or neglect. You know, the typical outcome when you experience those terrible things in childhood is developing anxiety or depression or post-traumatic stress among other problems.
反社会人格障碍诊断的人。所以，我会说有时这就是它的意思。其他时候，它被用来指那些反社会行为主要是社会力量结果的人。所以那些天生并没有特别高风险变得反社会，但由于发生在他们身上的非常可怕的事情，通常是在童年时期，经历极端的忽视、创伤或虐待，从而导致了反社会行为的人。现在，这甚至不是经历虐待的规范性后果。使用创伤或忽视。你知道，在童年经历那些可怕事情时的典型结果是发展出焦虑、抑郁或创伤后应激障碍等问题。
But some children do develop very serious antisocial behavior as a result of those outcomes. And so, you know, again, it's not technically the scientific term, but many people, when they talk about sociopathy, that's what they mean. There was no particular sort of innate risk factor. It was purely a social set of risk factors that caused their behavior, whereas psychopathy is almost always used to refer to people who are sort of have this innate set of risk factors that then become psychopathy as a result of different patterns that happen during development. In my intro, I mentioned some notorious people who are often thought of as psychopaths, and they were all men. And I just want to know, do we know whether psychopathy is more
但一些孩子确实因此发展出了非常严重的反社会行为。所以，你知道，再说一次，它在技术上不是科学术语，但许多人在谈论社会病态时，指的就是这个。没有特定的某种先天风险因素。纯粹是一套导致他们行为的社会风险因素，而精神病态几乎总是被用来指代那些某种程度上拥有这套先天风险因素，然后由于发育过程中发生的不同模式而导致精神病态的人。在我的介绍中，我提到了一些通常被认为是精神病态者的臭名昭著的人，他们都是男性。我只是想知道，我们是否知道精神病态在
prevalent among men or women, or does it just manifest differently depending on your sex? This is a wonderful question. And it's one that I think reasonable people could disagree on. We know that the scales that are most commonly used for assessing psychopathy now, probably the most famous of which is the PCLR, the psychopathy checklist, which was developed by Bob Hare. It was developed in an all-male adult population of prisoners in British Columbia. And I think that scale is really good for assessing psychopathy in adult male prisoners in North America. But I think reasonable people could differ as to how effective it is in assessing psychopathy in all its manifestations in other kinds of populations, non-prison populations, children and women. And there are other scales, I'll emphasize, that I really dislike the phrase gold standard when it comes to measuring any kind of construct.
男性还是女性中更普遍，还是它只是根据你的性别表现不同？这是一个很棒的问题。我认为理智的人可能会对此有分歧。我们知道，现在最常用于评估精神病态的量表，可能最著名的是由鲍勃·黑尔开发的PCLR（精神病态检查表）。它是在不列颠哥伦比亚省的男性成年囚犯群体中开发的。我认为该量表对于评估北美男性成年囚犯的精神病态确实很好。但我认为理智的人可能会对它在评估其他类型人群、非监狱人群、儿童和女性的所有表现形式中的精神病态的有效性有不同看法。还有其他量表，我会强调，我非常不喜欢在测量任何类型的结构时使用“黄金标准”这个短语。
You know, any measurement is never the same thing as the construct. It's just one way to measure it. And some of the measures that I often use to assess psychopathy were developed in more general populations. And so maybe better at capturing psychopathy in, for example, women. So it's possible. I will say that we do see lower levels of psychopathy in women using a lot of the scales that are used to measure it.
你知道，任何测量永远不等于结构本身。它只是测量它的一种方式。我经常用来评估精神病态的一些测量方法是在更广泛的人群中开发的。所以可能在捕捉精神病态方面更好，例如，在女性中。所以这是可能的。我会说，使用许多用于测量它的量表，我们确实在女性中看到了较低水平的精神病态。
This could be because the scales were developed. in more male populations, and so they don't capture psychopathy as well in women. You know, for example, they may emphasize physical aggression or different forms of violent crime that are much, much more likely to be engaged in by men than women. We know. And so they don't quite as accurately capture the ways that psychopathy manifests in women, which is much more likely to relate to social aggression. sort of emotional bullying, manipulation, that sort of thing.
这可能是因为这些量表是在更多男性人群中开发的。所以它们不能很好地捕捉女性的精神病态。你知道，例如，它们可能强调身体攻击或不同形式的暴力犯罪，这些犯罪男性比女性更有可能参与。我们知道。所以它们不能那么准确地捕捉精神病态在女性中表现出的方式，这更有可能与社会攻击有关。某种情感欺凌、操纵，诸如此类。
It's also possible that there are true gender differences. And I would believe that in part because we know from, you know, giant personality assessments that have been done in countries all over the world, that there are average differences in the personalities of men and women, with men tending to be a little lower in a trait called negative emotionality, a little lower in a trait called conscientiousness, and lower in trait agreeableness. These are all personality contracts
也有可能存在真正的性别差异。我相信这一点，部分是因为我们从世界各地进行的巨大的人格评估中知道，男性和女性的人格存在平均差异，男性在一种称为负面情绪的特质上往往略低，在一种称为尽责性的特质上略低，在宜人性特质上较低。这些都是人格结构
that do relate to psychopathy. People with psychopathy, not surprisingly, are less agreeable, less conscientious, and lower in some forms of negative emotion. And so given that, I think it's reasonable to say
确实与精神病态有关。不出所料，精神病态者更不宜人，更不尽责，并且在某些形式的负面情绪上较低。所以鉴于此，我认为说
that probably psychopathy at the tails will show up more often in men than women, and yet I think it's also true that we're undermeasuring it in women because the scales aren't picking up on some of the ways that it manifests. Now, if in your normal life you encounter people who you think have some of these traits, I mean, I asked in the intro, you know, what can you do? I mean, other than just trying to avoid
精神病态在极端情况下在男性中出现的频率可能高于女性是合理的，但我认为同样真实的是，我们在女性中低估了它，因为量表没有捕捉到它表现出的一些方式。现在，如果在你的正常生活中，你遇到了你认为具有其中一些特质的人，我的意思是，我在介绍中问过，你知道，你能做什么？我的意思是，除了尽量避免
people who are like this, is there anything that you can do to protect yourself from these kinds of people? Yes. The first thing I'll say is psychopathy does not present the way people think it does. I vividly remember the very first time I went to interview a child with psychopathy when I was a postdoc at the National Institute of Mental Health. And he was was, he had pretty severe psychopathy. He was in a locked psychiatric ward at the NIMH. He was there for a long-term study that his parents had enrolled him in. And I had heard these horrible stories about his behavior and the backgrounds, you know, uncontrollable violence. His parents, you know, would often take his brother to stay in a hotel for long periods of time. They were so worried
像这样的人，你有什么办法可以保护自己免受这类人的伤害吗？是的。我要说的第一件事是，精神病态的表现方式并不像人们想象的那样。我生动地记得我第一次去采访一个患有精神病态的儿童，当时我是在美国国立卫生研究院做博士后。他有相当严重的精神病态。他被关在国立卫生研究院的一个封闭的精神病房里。他是在那里参加他父母为他报名的长期研究。我听过关于他的行为和背景的那些可怕的故事，你知道，无法控制的暴力。他的父母，你知道，经常带他的兄弟去住酒店很长一段时间。他们非常担心
about this boy trying to, you know, really seriously hurt or even kill his brother. You know, when he was being punished, he would do awful things like smear his own hoop on the walls. It was really, it was, it was bad stuff. And so the last thing I expected to see when I walked into his room, you know, and I knew how to like, you know, keep my, no, sharp objects in my pocket and make sure that I never let him get between me and the door. I mean, all the normal things that you do when you work with potentially violent populations. But I walk into his room at the NIH and, you know, you know, up. from his, he was sitting on his bed and he pops up to shake my hand. It's just the cutest kid.
这个男孩试图，你知道，真的严重伤害甚至杀死他的兄弟。你知道，当他受到惩罚时，他会做可怕的事情，比如把自己的粪便涂在墙上。这真的很糟糕。所以当我走进他的房间时，我最后想到要看到的是，你知道，我知道如何，你知道，把我的，没有尖锐的物体放在口袋里，并确保我从不让他挡在我与门之间。我的意思是，当你与潜在的暴力人群一起工作时，你所做的所有正常事情。但我走进他在NIH的房间，你知道，你知道，他坐在床上，他跳起来和我握手。这只是个最可爱的孩子。
I mean, he looked like he was out of a serial commercial. Um, you know, like an adorable smile and just kind of sort of an aweshocks demeanor. Um, freckles on his nose. I mean, he just was so cute and sweet and friendly and charming. You know, he seemed more mentally healthy than the average child. It was just astonishing. Um, and he agreed that he had in engaged in all these bad behaviors that had resulted in him being at the NIMH. But there was always sort of an explanation for them. You know, oh, he just was having a really bad day that day. And, you know, looking back, maybe he shouldn't have done that. And that is what I learned in the most important lesson about psychopathy is that you can't tell when somebody has it because they have a craze look on their eye or they seem really gruff
我的意思是，他看起来就像是从连环画里走出来的一样。嗯，你知道，他有那种可爱的笑容，还有一种那种有点害羞的举止。嗯，鼻子上还有雀斑。我的意思是，他看起来那么可爱、甜美、友好且迷人。你知道，他看起来比一般的孩子心理更健康。这简直令人震惊。嗯，他也承认自己参与了所有那些导致他被送往美国国家心理健康研究所（NIMH）的不良行为。但对于这些行为，他总是有某种解释。你知道，哦，他那天只是过得很糟糕。而且，你知道，回想起来，也许他不该那样做。这就是我在关于精神病态方面学到的最重要的一课，那就是你无法通过某人是否有疯狂的眼神或看起来是否粗鲁来判断他们是否患有精神病态。
or there's, you know, weird eye contact. Some people say, oh, yeah, there's a certain thing that people with psychopathy do. I've never seen it personally. I think part of the reason is that I work with people who have not spent long time in prisons or institutions, which does things to your demeanor, obviously. People who are out in the community who have very high levels of psychopathy present as genuinely likable, charming, well-adjusted, friendly, often very helpful people in reality. I mean, this is how they manage to do all the terrible things that they do is because people don't see them.
或者，你知道，眼神交流是否奇怪。有些人说，哦，是的，患有精神病态的人有一种特定的表现。我个人从未见过。我认为部分原因是，我合作的对象并没有在监狱或机构中待过很长时间，这显然会影响一个人的举止。那些在社区中生活、具有极高精神病态水平的人，在现实中表现得非常讨人喜欢、迷人、适应良好、友好，而且往往非常乐于助人。我的意思是，这就是他们能够做出所有那些可怕事情的原因，因为人们根本没有预料到。
coming. I mean, Ted Bundy was infamous for that. And I will say that, you know, many serial killers are not psychopathic. Some of them have very odd, you know, forms of psychosis or compulsions or other problems. Usually it's some sort of perfect storm of multiple problems. Ted Bundy was highly psychopathic in addition to being a serial killer. But you never would guess it. I've, I've met psychology professors at the University of Washington who had Ted Bundy as their students and introduced him to their wives and wrote letters of recommendation for him and had absolutely no idea that he was simultaneously murdering women on the weekends when he wasn't in classes. You can't tell. If I lined up all the children with psychopathy that I've ever worked with over the years
我的意思是，泰德·邦迪（Ted Bundy）在这方面臭名昭著。我得说，你知道，许多连环杀手并不是精神病态者。他们中的一些人有非常奇怪的、你知道的，某种形式的精神病或强迫症或其他问题。通常这是多种问题共同作用的完美风暴。泰德·邦迪除了是连环杀手外，还具有高度的精神病态。但你永远也猜不到。我见过华盛顿大学的心理学教授，他们曾教过泰德·邦迪，还把他介绍给自己的妻子，为他写推荐信，却完全不知道他在周末不上课的时候同时在谋杀女性。你无法分辨。如果我把我多年来合作过的所有患有精神病态的孩子排成一排，
and all the healthy kids that I've worked with over the years and asked you to pick out who's who you'd never be able to tell. So this is the first part of making sure that you can protect yourself from psychopathy. It's just not assuming that it will look like your stereotype of it. The most important thing you can keep track of is how people treat other people. It's very hard to detect in somebody you've just met. But if you get to know somebody for a little while, the things to look up for are, first of all, different people having extremely different impressions of them. You know, some people saying that this person is like a really horrible person, other people saying this person is the nicest person in the world. That kind of chameleon-like behavior is not always indicative of psychopity, but sometimes it is.
把我多年来合作过的所有健康的孩子也排成一排，让你挑出谁是谁，你永远也分辨不出来。所以，这是确保你能保护自己免受精神病态伤害的第一步。就是不要假设它会像你刻板印象中的那样。你能追踪的最重要的事情是人们如何对待他人。在你刚认识的人身上很难察觉。但如果你和某人相处了一段时间，需要注意的事情是，首先，不同的人对他们有截然不同的印象。你知道，有些人说这个人是个非常糟糕的人，而另一些人说这个人是世界上最好的人。那种变色龙般的行为并不总是精神病态的征兆，但有时确实是。
The other thing you look for is a pattern of behavior that suggests this person does not really care about anybody but themselves, right? Do they ever actually do anything that sacrifices their own welfare to help anybody else, including, you know, people that they say are friends or that they love? Do they really seem affected and truly moved when other people are suffering? Do they seem just a little too glib, just a little too able to kind of talk their way out of situations? So they always seem to be kind of scurting just on the edge of acceptable behavior and not seem to think that maybe the rules apply to them as much as they do to other people. Those are the kinds of things you want to look for when you're just in daily life and think that somebody may have high levels of psychopathy. I should also mention that there are people who are fairly callous people who have most of the traits of psychopathy who are actually just fine people to know in your life. you know, I wouldn't necessarily let them, you know, propose, you know, an outing to go white
你要寻找的另一件事是一种行为模式，暗示这个人除了自己以外并不真正关心任何人，对吧？他们是否真的做过任何牺牲自己的利益去帮助别人的事情，包括，你知道，他们说是朋友或他们爱的人？当别人受苦时，他们看起来真的受到影响并真正感动了吗？他们看起来是否有点太油嘴滑舌，太能为自己的处境辩解了？他们是否总是看起来游走在可接受行为的边缘，似乎并不认为规则像适用于其他人那样适用于他们自己？当你身处日常生活中，认为某人可能具有高水平的精神病态时，这些就是你需要寻找的迹象。我还应该提到，有些人是相当冷酷的人，他们拥有精神病态的大部分特征，但实际上在你的生活中是很好的人。你知道，我不一定会让他们，你知道，提议去进行一次白水漂流之类的活动。
river rafting or anything like that. You know, many people with psychopies say they often get their friends into a lot of trouble. But the most important predictor of future behavior is past behavior. And so, you know, I know people who have psychopathy who have learned that if they treat other people well, it works better for them too. And so oftentimes they can make good friends. you just have to always be aware of what you can and can't count on them for. Let's switch gears and talk about the happier side of your research, which is about empathy, compassion, and those extreme altruists like the people who donate kidneys to strangers. What's the connection between what seems on its face to be the opposite extreme of human behavior?
你知道，许多患有精神病态的人说他们经常给朋友惹很多麻烦。但预测未来行为的最重要指标是过去的行为。所以，你知道，我认识一些患有精神病态的人，他们已经了解到，如果他们善待他人，对自己也更有利。因此，他们往往能成为好朋友。你只需要时刻意识到在什么事情上可以依靠他们，在什么事情上不能。让我们换个话题，谈谈你研究中更快乐的一面，也就是关于同理心、同情心以及那些极端利他主义者，比如那些给陌生人捐献肾脏的人。在表面上看起来是人类行为的相反极端之间，有什么联系吗？
Yeah, so I've been incredibly fortunate in my research career to have been able to work not only with people who have psychopathy or at risk for psychopathy, who, to be honest, I really enjoy that research. I really feel for the parents of the kids who have psychopathy, but I really enjoy the kids themselves. But I've also worked with people who were on the other end of what I call the caring continuum, who are unusually caring and altruistic to the point that they will even give kidneys to strangers or rescue other people from fires or drowning.
是的，在我的研究生涯中，我非常幸运，不仅能够与那些患有精神病态或有精神病态风险的人合作，说实话，我真的很喜欢那项研究。我真的很同情那些患有精神病态孩子的父母，但我真的很喜欢这些孩子本身。但我也曾与那些处于我所说的“关怀连续体”另一端的人合作过，他们异常关怀和利他，甚至愿意给陌生人捐献肾脏，或者从火灾或溺水中救出他人。
And the genesis of this research was the relatively recent, understanding that psychopathy is not like a discrete group or tax on. It's not like we have psychopaths here and then the rest of the population over here. It's a continuum. You know, there are people who have mildly psychopathic traits. Some people have moderately or very severely psychopathic traits. So it's, you know, like a lot of things. It's sort of a normal distribution. Well, not a normal distribution, but certainly a distribution. And that discovery prompted me to wonder, while if it's a distribution with super uncaring, uncompassion people on one end, and most of us somewhere in the middle, what's on the other end?
这项研究的起源是相对较近的理解，即精神病态不像是一个离散的群体或分类。并不是说我们这里有精神病态者，而其余的人口在这里。这是一个连续体。你知道，有些人有轻微的精神病态特征。有些人有中度或非常严重的精神病态特征。所以，你知道，就像很多事情一样。这是一种正态分布。好吧，不是正态分布，但肯定是一种分布。这一发现促使我思考，如果这是一个分布，一端是超级冷漠、缺乏同情心的人，而我们大多数人处于中间的某个位置，那么另一端是什么？
And if we can understand what it looks like to be sort of anti-psychopathic, that could help us learn a lot about the origins of compassion and care, which are the things that my research focuses on. And so after a bit of thinking, the population I landed on to see if they looked anti-psychopathic was people who donate kidneys to strangers. Because if there's any behavior that indicates more care about the welfare of other people, even total strangers, it's that when you're willing to give up an internal organ, a vital internal organ at significant sometimes expense and inconvenience and sometimes serious pain
如果我们能理解那种“反精神病态”是什么样子，那将有助于我们了解同情心和关怀的起源，这也是我研究的重点。所以经过一番思考，我选定的群体是那些给陌生人捐献肾脏的人，看看他们是否看起来是“反精神病态”的。因为如果有什么行为能表明对他人福利的更多关怀，甚至是完全陌生人的福利，那就是当你愿意放弃一个内部器官，一个重要的内部器官，有时要付出巨大的代价、不便，有时甚至是严重的痛苦时，
to yourself, I don't know what it is. It's a really sort of a magnificent act of generosity. And so about 10 years ago, I started bringing altruistic kidney donors to my lab at Georgetown to conduct brain scanning research with them. And one of the first things we found about them is that they are indeed sort of anti-psychopaths. They have amygdalas, whereas people who are psychopathic have amygdalas that tend to be too small and not active enough. People who were very altruistic have amygdalas that are larger than average and tend to be
对自己来说，我不知道那是什么。这真是一种宏大的慷慨行为。所以大约10年前，我开始把利他肾脏捐赠者带到我在乔治城大学的实验室，对他们进行脑部扫描研究。我们发现关于他们的第一件事是，他们确实是某种“反精神病态者”。他们有杏仁核，而患有精神病态的人的杏仁核往往太小且不够活跃。非常利他的人的杏仁核比平均水平大，并且倾向于
even more responsive to cues like the sight of other people in distress. So if you show them a picture of somebody who looks very afraid, they have a bigger than average in the other response to it. And that seems to support they're being better able at recognizing when other people are in distress. So if you show them fearful faces, they're better than average at recognizing them. And I think that means that they have the personalities that are unusually caring, and responsive to other people's need and suffering, and that makes them unusually motivated to help when other people are in need or suffering.
对诸如看到他人处于困境之类的线索反应更灵敏。所以如果你给他们看一张看起来非常害怕的人的照片，他们对此的反应比平均水平要大。这似乎支持了他们能更好地识别他人何时处于困境。所以如果你给他们看恐惧的表情，他们识别这些表情的能力比平均水平要好。我认为这意味着他们拥有异常关怀、对他人需求和痛苦反应灵敏的个性，这使他们在他人需要或受苦时异常有动力去提供帮助。
And you yourself are the benefactor of somebody who was apparently one of these altruists, right? I mean, can you tell that story? Because it's kind of amazing. I saw your TED talk about it. Oh, thank you. Yes, he certainly was a true altruist. Yeah, it happened when I was a teenager, and I certainly credited for the trajectory
而你自己就是这些利他主义者之一的受益者，对吧？我的意思是，你能讲讲那个故事吗？因为它真的很神奇。我看了你关于它的TED演讲。哦，谢谢。是的，他确实是一位真正的利他主义者。是的，那发生在我十几岁的时候，我肯定把它归功于我研究生涯所走的轨迹。
that my research career has taken. Yeah, I was driving home on Interstate 5, the Moore Treeway and Washington State, back to my hometown of Tacoma, also the hometown of Ted Bundy, and the hometown of the Green River Keller, and several other similar notorious. There's not an accident. There's something in the water. Yeah, I know. There's no way it's an accident that I'm also injured in psychopathy.
是的，我当时正开车在5号州际公路上，那是华盛顿州的摩尔高速公路，回我的家乡塔科马，那也是泰德·邦迪的家乡，绿河杀手的家乡，以及其他几个类似臭名昭著的人的家乡。那不是意外。水里肯定有什么东西。是的，我知道。我研究精神病态绝非偶然。
In any case, so I'm driving on an overpass back into town, when a very strong. small dog ran out in front of my car, which how it got there, I'll never know. And I swerved to avoid it, which I now know you shouldn't do, even though the impulse is always there. And the combination of hitting the dog and swerving to avoid it caused my car to spin out of control. It was fish tailing and then literally spinning in giant circles across the freeway until finally it came to arrest in the fast lane of the freeway just over the crest of the crest of the this overpass so that the oncoming cars couldn't see me until they were almost on top of me. And the engine died.
无论如何，我当时正开车经过一个立交桥回到城里，这时一只非常强壮的小狗跑到了我的车前，它是怎么到那里的，我永远也不会知道。我猛打方向盘避开了它，我现在知道你不应该这样做，尽管冲动总是存在的。撞到狗和猛打方向盘避开它的结合导致我的车失控了。它先是甩尾，然后真的在高速公路上打着巨大的圈旋转，直到最后停在高速公路的快车道上，就在这个立交桥的坡顶上方，所以迎面而来的车直到快撞上我时才看到我。引擎熄火了。
And I was 100% sure that I was also going to die because I had a phone, couldn't get the car to turn back on. There was no shoulder for me to escape to. I literally, you know, I kept, I just remember trying to turn the car back on and being unable to do so. And so I don't know how long I sat there. I mean, time does funny things when you think you're about to die. But what ended up happening was as I was sitting there, you know, waiting for the end,
我百分之百确定我也要死了，因为我有手机，但无法让车重新启动。没有路肩让我逃生。我真的，你知道，我记得我一直在试图重新启动车，却无法做到。所以我不知道我坐在那里坐了多久。我的意思是，当你认为自己快要死的时候，时间会变得很奇怪。但最终发生的事情是，当我坐在那里，你知道，等待结局时，
I hear a rap on the passenger's side door, which was the side next to the shoulder and turned to see a man standing there who I later figured out. It must have pulled his car over on the opposite side of the freeway within second of having seen my stranded car and then run across the freeway to reach me again in the middle of the night at the dark with cars and trucks flying past. And to make a long story short, he got in my car and got it back up and running again, which required putting it back in park, and then got us back to safety on the other side of the freeway. And then disappeared. He's like, are you going to be okay? Do you need me to follow you before you get home just to make sure you get home okay? And I said, no, no, I'll be okay.
我听到有人敲副驾驶侧的车门，那是靠近路肩的一侧，转头看到一个男人站在那里，我后来想通了。他一定是在看到我抛锚的车后几秒钟内就把车停在了高速公路的对面，然后跑过高速公路来到我身边，那是在深夜，周围有汽车和卡车飞驰而过。长话短说，他上了我的车，让它重新启动了，这需要把它挂回停车档，然后把我们带回了高速公路另一侧的安全地带。然后消失了。他就像是，你没事吧？你需要我跟着你直到你回家以确保你安全到家吗？我说，不，不，我会没事的。
And he said, okay, well, then you take care of yourself. And off he went into the night. I don't know his name. I don't know anything about him. But I know that he was truly heroic. Yeah. Yeah. It's quite an amazing story. Last question. I mean, I like to ask this a lot of researchers. What are the big questions that are fascinating you now? What are you working on? And in your mind, sort of the most important questions that we could still answer. Oh, there are so many. I mean, it's one of the reasons I absolutely love being a psychology researcher and a neuroscience researcher is because these are relatively young, And there are so many things we still have to know. And plus, I mean, what's more interesting than trying to understand human psychology and behavior? I think the most interesting question and certainly the one that I'm in the middle of pursuing is what is it that allows somebody to truly care about somebody else? I mean, you know, when you really boil it down, it's love,
他说，好吧，那你照顾好自己。然后他就消失在夜色中了。我不知道他的名字。我对他一无所知。但我知道他确实是英雄。是的。是的。这是一个非常神奇的故事。最后一个问题。我的意思是，我喜欢问很多研究人员这个问题。现在让你着迷的大问题是什么？你在研究什么？在你看来，我们仍然可以回答的最重要的问题是什么？哦，有太多了。我的意思是，我绝对热爱成为一名心理学研究员和神经科学研究员的原因之一就是因为这些学科还相对年轻，而且我们还有很多东西需要了解。而且，我的意思是，还有什么比试图理解人类心理和行为更有趣的呢？我认为最有趣的问题，当然也是我正在追求的问题，是什么让人能够真正关心另一个人？我的意思是，你知道，当你真正归结起来时，它是爱，
which I know is a little bit of a fluffy term and sometimes researchers try to avoid it. But, you know, the scientific definition of love is to care about somebody else's welfare for its own sake, not because of how it affects you. And, you know, from having worked with altruists for 10 years now, I genuinely believe that it's possible and at common to genuinely care about the welfare of other people because they're intrinsically valuable to you. And how does the brain enable that, right? How do we have this capacity?
我知道这是一个有点虚无的词，有时研究人员会尽量避免使用它。但是，你知道，爱的科学定义是出于关心他人的福利本身，而不是因为它如何影响你。而且，你知道，在与利他主义者合作了10年之后，我真诚地相信，真正关心他人的福利是可能的，也是常见的，因为他们在你眼中具有内在价值。大脑是如何实现这一点的，对吧？我们怎么会有这种能力？
to genuinely care about other people. There must be some pathway in the brain that enables it, probably built on the pathways that originally evolved to support parenting, which is, of course, the original form of love is the love that parents have for their offspring. And we think that in general, most forms of care-based altruism emerge out of the capacities for parental care. And so I would love to try to figure out how it is that the brain enables that capacity to emerge. I think it's, I mean, it's the most beautiful form of alchemy I can imagine. I'd love to figure out the answer.
去真正关心他人。大脑中一定有一些通路能够实现这一点，可能建立在最初为了支持育儿而进化的通路之上，当然，爱的最初形式就是父母对后代的爱。我们认为，总的来说，大多数基于关怀的利他主义形式都是从父母关怀的能力中产生的。所以我很想弄清楚大脑是如何使这种能力得以显现的。我认为，我的意思是，这是我能想象到的最美丽的炼金术。我很想找出答案。
Well, thank you so much for joining me today, Dr. Marsh. This has been really interesting. I appreciate you're taking the time to explain your work to the world. It's been a pleasure. Thank you so much for inviting me here. You can learn more about Dr. Marsh's work and other research on psychopathy in the March issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. Go to our show notes for the link at speakingof psychology.org.
好吧，非常感谢你今天加入我，马什博士。这真的很有趣。我很感谢你花时间向世界解释你的工作。这是我的荣幸。非常感谢你邀请我来这里。你可以在美国心理学会（APA）的杂志《心理学监测》（Monitor on Psychology）三月刊中了解更多关于马什博士的工作和其他关于精神病态的研究。请前往我们的节目说明获取链接，网址是 speakingofpsychology.org。
You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology there or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you listen to us on Apple, please leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiant. Thank you for listening.
你也可以在那里或在Apple、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology）之前的剧集。如果你在Apple上收听我们，请留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学对话》由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪安特（Chris Condiant）。感谢您的收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。